bonjour à tous excusez nous pour ce
petit contretemps technique nous sommes
en direct sur figaro live merci de nous
retrouver en direct également sur notre
chaîne youtube vous le voyez sur les
images qu'on va vous diffusée dans
quelques secondes depuis ce matin des
supporters des marseillais se sont
rassemblés sur le vieux port de
marseille et le vieux port de la cité
phocéenne pour accompagner le cortège
funéraire jusqu'à la major la major la
cathédrale à sainte marie majeure située
face à la méditerranée dans laquelle se
tiendra une messe à partir de 11 heures
une cérémonie qui sera présidée par
l'archevêque de marseille monseigneur
jean marc aveline bernard tapie sera
ensuite inhumé au cimetière de mazargues
dans le quartier sud de la ville on va
commenter cet événement en direct avec
mon invité cédric qu'allié journaliste
au figaro sport bonjour cédric merci
d'être en direct avec nous on commentera
également c'était cet événement
particulier avec notre envoyé spécial à
marseille sache habilite un sacha benita
et bien justement on va le retrouver
tout de suite sacha benita au milieu des
supporters et des marseillais
marseillais rassemblés ce matin sacha si
vous m'entendez
après après l'hommage des supporters
hier au stade vélodrome c'est de nouveau
un moment de communion très fort on le
voit aujourd'hui entre eux les
marseillais bernard tapie
oui charlotte tout à fait alors bonjour
à tous je me trouve effectivement au
niveau du vieux port où il ya une
procession qui va donc commencer le
cortège funéraire est passé il ya
quelques minutes et là les supporters se
sont réunis depuis ce matin 9h et il ya
plusieurs centaines de personnes donc on
a déjà eu l'occasion de parler avec
certains d'entre eux on a rencontré
notamment nathalie et céline qui étaient
dans le stade à l'époque en 93
et
qui ont vécu ces ambiances
la présidence de bernard tapie et là on
entend encore les supporters cris juste
derrière moi scandant des chants avec le
nom de tapis
voilà on a également rencontré
des ultras qui en 93 n'avait que 20 ans
pour eux c'est quand même une émotion
forte puisque
ici c'est vraiment le papa de marseille
marc la vie c'est le boss de 10 m
le rap est la plaie eux
un sens
dans chaque interview dans chaque
personne pour rencontre
laver voilà il
une
potentiel pour réussir à motiver les
troupes et donner
c'est cet esprit de combativité
l'or a réussi un entrepreneur
yu
présentant un club de supporters bail si
aujourd'hui la
tous ceux qui ont une valeur et
inculquée par
tapie à l'époque voilà derrière les
centaines de supporters qui sont en
train de défiler en direction de
cathédrale de la major
[Applaudissements]
dd on va dire des slogans en hommage à
bernard tapie et on les entend derrière
vous on les voit aussi je crois qu'il ya
un dress code qui était imposé je crois
qu'il fallait se vêtir de noir et
portait les écharpes bleu et blanc de
l'olympique de marseille c'est ça
[Applaudissements]
exactement il ya il ya effectivement
matthew c'est sûr ils sont vêtus
mais
laisse transparaître même
du blanc
lors des chars des maillots des
casquettes
tout bleu
ça y est aujourd'hui
ce sourire dans les coeurs en tout cas
aussi proches que l'étoile eux bernard
tapie sur le coeur à l'époque
c'est le premier club
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup de monde au revoir sacha
militaire on imagine que le procès celle
que le dispositif de sécurité a été
adapté par la préfecture de police qui
n'avait pas voulu qu'une profession soit
mise en place hier
aujourd'hui on voit un cortège funéraire
va se déplacer du vieux port jusqu'à la
major vous l'avez vu ce dispositif de
sécurité il est imposant
ce matin je suis passé
le niveau 2
de la major
un véhicule
avec des barrières qui ans pour essayer
de contenir et
protéger la poule là
passé que veut que vont réaliser les
supporters jusqu'à et jusqu'à la
cathédrale
c'est des véhicules de police des
motards qui sont là pour encadrer
[Musique]
à faire en sorte que tout se passe bien
voilà quelques fumigènes sont déjà
allumé dans la folle jeunesse dès 16
heures
[Applaudissements]
pu dîner de nous rejoindre
en direct sur figaro l'arrivée sur notre
chaîne youtube nous sommes en train de
vous faire vivre les obsèques de bernard
tapie
l'ancien businessman
danton on célèbre les obsèques
aujourd'hui c'est le jour des obsèques à
marseille le retour à la maison du boss
comme le surnomment les ultras et les
supporters marseillais c'est d'être
qu'alliez vous êtes avec nous en direct
vous êtes journaliste au figaro sport du
figaro et sport24 vous êtes là avec nous
pour commenter en direct cet événement
si particulier et puis aussi pour
répondre aux questions et commentaires
des internautes c'est je disais un
retour à la maison d'un parisien
pourtant bernard tapie était parisien et
et ont dit qu'ils retournent à la maison
comment expliquer cette espèce de
paradoxe on va dire propre petit basse
et c'est peut-être sa plus grande
réussite parce que effectivement quand
on est parisien de se faire aimer des
marseillais c'est pas simple lui s'est
pas fait mais s'il fait adorer il fait à
bulles est donc déjà cessé c'est
différent c'est vrai qu'il ya un vrai
retour à la maison comme vous dites
parce qu'il ya moi j'ai entendu beaucoup
de supporters hier au vélodrome dire il
a été des plus marseillais que les
marseillais finalement dans les coeurs
donc il il a vraiment cette histoire
d'amour qui est né en 86 quand il
reprend la tête du club ça a été
il a été président de l'om que sept ans
finalement ça a été assez court mais ça
a été tellement intense tellement fort
avec une telle réussite et puis l'un
calmes en tant que comme sans doute un
petit peu les valeurs de cette ville
dans les valeurs positives peut être un
peu négative aussi il faut pas l'oublier
mais mais c'est l'incarnation de
marseille bernard tapie alors marseille
les hommages qui se succèdent depuis
mercredi
depuis l'annoncé de son décès dimanche
dernier on a pu assister en particulier
à une messe funéraire à paris à saint
germain des prés en présence d'un
certain nombre de personnalités du monde
politique du monde de la culture du
cinéma de la chanson pourra citer
brigitte macron
nicolas sarkozy jeux de mémoire et
rachida dati brice hortefeux et dans le
les personnalités du monde du spectacle
on a pu voir claude lelouch didier
barbelivien il y avait aussi des anciens
joueurs de l'om qui seront probablement
présent également aujourd'hui basile
boli jean pierre papin qui ont
d'ailleurs porté le cercueil de bernard
tapie au sortir de cette église de saint
germain des prés on en voit les images
que veut bien nous montrer en régie et
raphaël lazreg donc c'est une une
rediffusion un des images de mercredi
qui ont beaucoup ému
on voit aussi le fils de bernard tapie
stéphane tapis jean louis borloo qui
était également un politique très proche
un ami de bernard tapie la
collaboratrice de bernard tapie groupe
et de la présidente lui des présidents
de bernard tapie groupe aux côtés de
basile boli jean pierre papin basile
boli donc ses proches très proches de
bernard tapie était présent avec lui
pour pour cet hommage la fille de
bernard tapie également
les deux filles je pense de bernard
tapie donc ça ce sont les images qu'on a
récupéré deux de cette messe funéraire
qui a eu lieu à saint germain des prés à
paris mercredi et puis on a pu voir hier
un hommage encore une fois
extraordinaire au sens premier du terme
comme était le personnage ces images du
vélodrome si raphaël lazreg peut nous
les montrer de ce cercueil porté
jusqu'au centre sur la pelouse du stade
vélodrome face à aux supporters
marseillais avec des chants qui ont été
entonnés
e
je pense à la queen groupe queen qui à
chanter we are the champions et puis
aussi jump qui a été
voilà on n'a pas le son de ces images
mais c'était effectivement un moment
très particulier très émouvant donc il
s'est déroulé hier au coeur du stade
vélodrome qu'est ce qu'on peut en dire
de ces images absolument inédite pour un
président de club de football personne
n'a eu le droit à un tel traitement moi
que ça reste sans doute peut-être le
plus grand président d'un club de
football de toute l'histoire en france
et peut-être est-ce qu'en europe s'ils
ont
éventuellement silvio berlusconi à milan
aussi incarné la réussite et en plus
c'était quelqu'un qui était proche de
bernard tapie dans le style non ça ça
démontre vraiment l'amour immodéré de
cette ville pour pour ce président je le
disais tout à l'heure il a il a repris
le club en 86 quand il prend le club il
prend pas un club à succès il prend un
club qui vient de finir 12e du
championnat de france qui est un club
relativement anonyme certes ya déjà une
passion qui forte dans la ville pour le
football mais c'est lui c'est lui qui va
construire la réussite de marseille
c'est lui qui va l'incarner c'est lui
qui va aller chercher les joueurs qui va
aller chercher les entraîneurs les
directeurs sportifs
aujourd'hui paris saint-germain achètent
des grandes stars mais il n'avance rien
le paris saint-germain bernard tapie
avait fait bien avant déjà dans la fin
des années 80 il va chercher des
francescoli des giresse des tigana y
donne sa chance à des jeunes le psg a
pris mba p bernard tapie avait pris jean
pierre papin ce n'était pas une star
quand il est arrivé à marseille on peut
même peut-être citer aussi c'est un cas
lié
l'hypothèse qui avait été évoqué mais
très avancé de faire venir maradona à
l'olympique de marseille bah oui alors
il aurait adoré c'était il l'a fait avec
beckenbauer dans le staff technique qui
était le kaiser est où maintenant s'il
avait pu faire venir maradona s'il avait
été
président encore dans l'est on va dire
dans les années 2000 il aurait essayé de
faire venir ronaldo ou messi peut-être
plus ronaldo et messi mais parce que ça
correspondait sans doute plus à son
image et à ce qu'ils aimaient véhiculées
dans le football on le voit sur ces
images cédric en direct depuis marseille
vial afp le cortège funéraire qui a
priori s'est mise en route en tout cas
les voitures officielles et le cercueil
de bernard tapie viennent d'arriver sur
sur le vieux-port vous le voyez une
foule nombreuse de supporters de
marseillais qui se sont réunis depuis
tôt ce matin sur le vieux port pour
accompagner ce cortège funéraire jusqu'à
la cathédrale la major qui fait face à
la mer de sur cette cité phocéenne et où
se déroulera
la messe
concernant les obsèques de bernard tapie
donc à 11 heures dans une petite heure
maintenant nous avons sur place notre
envoyé spécial sacha benita qu'il
reviendra vers nous dans quelques
minutes peut-être pour avoir un peu
l'émotion et les propos les témoignages
des marseillais et des supporters réunis
ce matin et qui comme vous le voyez sur
ces images sont en nombre dans marseille
sur le port pour dire au revoir à au
boss comme il le surnommait et à cet
homme qui selon les marseillais a
beaucoup fait pour la ville de marseille
via son club l'olympique de marseille
cédric alliés ça m'amuse et en préparant
cette émission de lire que probablement
nombreux sont les marseillais qui
pensent que que bernard tapie et
marseillais alors qu'il est né dans le
20e arrondissement à paris parce que
parce que il sait il a déjà il a tout
compris dans le fonctionnement du club
il a toujours respecté les supporters il
a toujours respecté l'esprit de la ville
de marseille donc et ça quelque part je
pense qu'au départ les marseillais ont
été surpris de ça parce que voilà il va
y arriver un parisien l'homme d'affaires
certes qui avait déjà réussi un peu dans
le sport dans le cyclisme mais qui qui
hormis sa passion pour le football
n'avait encore rien démontré est il là
il a vraiment il a saisit l'âme de la
ville et ça c'est vraiment et surtout en
93 avec la victoire en ligue des
champions mais déjà en 91 quand
marseille dispute sa première finale il
a rendu les marseillais fier il faut
voir que déjà à l'époque c'est encore
plus le cas aujourd'hui souvent
marseille et est dépeint de manière
négative
bernard tapie a donné une image très
positive de la ville à travers le club
de football à travers sa passion et sa
cette fierté cet amour les marseillais
sont en train de lui rendre aujourd'hui
et on le voit sur ces images qui
rappellent la zac peu et julienc une
aile en régie peuvent nous donner un peu
de sens sur ces images que nous
découvrons directe est que nous vivons
avec vous en direct de cette foule de
supporters qui accompagnent le cortège
on n'a pas de retour sont alors
peut-être que vous vous lavez depuis le
figaro.fr et sur youtube on n'a pas le
retour et le son sur sur ces images
cédric alliés en préparant cette
émission je lisais que vous écriviez que
il à vous l'avais dit je crois avec
vincent roux dimanche dernier que
bernard tapie a mis marseille sur une
carte assez exactement ça c'est
aujourd'hui l'importance du football et
elle
que ça soit positif ou négatif que le
rayonnement d'une ville peut venir tout
simplement d'un club de football et
aujourd'hui enfin on va pas non plus
tout où m dresser des lauriers trop
importants bernard tapie marseille a été
une très grande ville française avant
mais vraiment c'est ce que je disais
auparavant il lui a donné une image
positive une image de réussite un club
qui gagne c'est une ville qui gagnent
quelque part surtout sur le sur le plan
européen quand vous gagnez la ligue des
champions aucun club français n'avait
fait même même la grande équipe de
saint-etienne avait avait échoué
pour remporter cette ligue des champions
donc les marseillais sont quand même
fier je le lis encore mais tellement
souvent aujourd'hui le même de gens qui
n'étaient même pas nés à l'époque à
jamais les premiers pour dire qu'ils
sont les premiers à avoir gagné sa
petite des champions donc en france bien
évidemment donc cesser c'est vraiment
oui cette idée de les avoir placés sur
une carte en europe marseille est
respectée marseille est connue
principalement aujourd'hui grâce à son à
son club de football si vous venez nous
rejoindre en direct sur figaro l'avait
notre chaîne youtube nous faisons vivre
les obsèques de bernard tapie l'homme
d'affaires
sera inhumé aujourd'hui à marseille en
amont 11 heures se déroulera une messe
dans la cathédrale de la major qui fait
face à la méditerranée dans cette
magnifique cité phocéenne dont on voit
les images en direct il fait très beau à
marseille ce n'est pas surprenant malgré
les inondations qui ont dévasté un peu
la ville il ya quelques jours le beau
temps est revenu et on le voit sur ces
images
la foule accompagnent le cortège
funéraire le cercueil de bernard tapie
une foule composée essentiellement de
supporters qui ont donné le mot hier
pour venir se rassembler ce matin dès 9
heures sur le vieux port et accompagner
donc ce cercueil de bernard tapie
jusqu'à la cathédrale de la major des
marseillais dont on a pu entendre qu'il
avait suivi le parcours de bernard tapie
via l'olympique de marseille depuis tout
petit on entendait sacha bénite à notre
envoyé spécial nous en parlait ce matin
on le retrouvera dans quelques minutes
vous êtes nombreux à suivre cet
événement via les réseaux sociaux du
figaro et nombreux également à vous dire
que on met beaucoup d' enthousiasme à
couvrir ces événements on met beaucoup
les supporters et la ville de marseille
depuis hier ont mis aussi beaucoup
d'énergie à couvrir et à rendre hommage
à la disparition de bernard tapie et
pour certains d'entre vous vous mettez
en avant également le fait que
finalement les affaires elle devrait
plutôt ternir le personnage et cédric
alliés quand on parlait de l'amour des
marseillais pour bernard tapie
effectivement on a l'impression que que
ses fans olympiens ne lui tiennent pas
du tout rigueur des affaires qui ont
accompagné la carrière de bernard tapie
il reste le boss malgré les affaires je
vais citer simplement romss 37 91 qui
nous dit on a oublié les affaires dans
le sport dans le domaine de l'entreprise
les procès et s'est accompagnée qui ont
accompagné la vie de bernard tapie il
ajoute combien d'emplois supprimés dans
les années 80-90
les les français ne devrait en lots ne
pas se réjouir autant qu est-ce qu on
peut répondre à ses internautes
ce qu'on peut répondre c'est que des
gens nés à marseille donc je pense qu'à
marseille ils sont concentrés
aujourd'hui pour rendre hommage au
président du club donc voilà
effectivement cet internaute souligne un
certain nombre d'affaires qui ont
finalement n'ont rien à voir avec le
football qui n'ont finalement rien à
voir avec avec le club de marseille donc
on pourrait on pourrait s'offusquer d'un
grand hommage national par rapport à ces
affaires là par contre ça on est
vraiment dans le jeu d'hier entre
guillemets microcosme footballistique
marseillais et pour ça alors c'est vrai
que
comme vous le dites les supporters
marseillais on n'y ont jamais tenu
rigueur la sphère au mba de cette
affaire de corruption
parce que parce qu'il ya eu la ligue des
champions parce qu'il ya eu quatre
titres de champion de france parce qu'il
ya une équipe qui les a fait rêver et
que
dans le coeur des supporters quand on
fait la balance entre le positif et le
négatif
on va pas se mentir bernard tapie la
balance est incroyablement positive ce
qui ne signifie pas d'oublier certaines
dérives voilà il a c'est ce que je
disais un peu aussi au début c'est qui
il symbolise tellement cette ville de
marseille qui l'a ce qui la symbolise
aussi dans certaines certaines parties
plus négative voilà ils avaient une part
d'ombré c'était c'était quelqu'un qui
avait tout compris au football y compris
ses aspects négatifs et y compris des
fois peut-être comment on peut être pas
comment gagner parce que cette affaire
au mba était vraiment une affaire entre
guillemets de pieds nickelés puisque il
a aurait acheté des joueurs uniquement
pour protéger à quelques jours de la
finale contre le milan ac pour éviter
des blessures des choses comme ça
donc c'était une petite c'était une
grande affaire mais pour de petites
raison
justement qui
comme au milieu d'un stade
à clame
bernard tapie dans le cortège funéraire
on écoutait ce que la régie comité un
peu le volume sonore en plateau pour
nous permettre de d'apprécier la
considère sur place
on est
notre envoyé spécial
lors de ce corps sacha mais buta je ne
sais pas si vous m'entendez
est-ce que vous pouvez nous entend
toujours très bien est-ce que vous
pouvez nous raconter un peu ce qui se
passe sur place
on entendait de loin les supporters
chantent et acclamé
bernard tapie dont le cercueil et dans
ce cortège funéraire dites-nous tout
sacha benita
les chansons de plus en plus fort c'est
toujours évident ici il ya une haie
d'honneur
autour du temps ces jeux
c'est une personne est monté sur une
échelle pour supporter de nouveaux
champs et toute la foule l'acclamé juste
à côté de moi il ya jean charles jean
charles est qui
pour qu'ils aient
supporté
vous étiez au biberon
petit peu ce qui s'est passé dans ses
serveurs
triste hasard la force donc c'est vrai
que ferveur parce que les gens étaient
toutes les content
réunir et de se recueillir en fait la
famille auprès du
du corps et la tristesse parce que parce
que c'est un foyer
la famille mais c'était c'était
particulier sur les particuliers ces
deux mélanges de cristal
surtout quand il est entré sur la
pelouse avec la musique de james était
jamais besoin d'encore les prix sont pas
ce que c'est
aujourd'hui vous travaillez vous avez au
bureau juste à côté et vous êtes quand
même venu encore aujourd'hui compagnie
oui c'est très important d'être là tous
les jours c'est important pour nous
parce qu'il a quand même mis l'europe la
nook et donc c'est avec votre login donc
et c'est oui c'était de lui rendre
hommage une dernière fois
j'ai scanné les valeurs
ta vie vous inculquer alors
le père de tous ici
ce soir
m
vraiment trouvé description
pas désinvolture mais cette facilité dès
fois à roppongi écueil pu trouver des
solutions c'est vrai
du coup même chose
on
une ambiance
quelques pas les races
aujourd'hui vous allez encore au stade
illusion
encore cette ferveur cette ambiance de
tapis comment ça se ressent dans le
stade bas elle sait
décrire faut le vivre il faut aller sur
place il faut le voir donc on ira
dimanche prochain contre lorient aussi
la compagnie
mais il faut se vit ça c'est des clips
pour lui
merci beaucoup de gens chardon
vous voyez c'est ce que je vous ai
expliqué ce matin j'ai un peu de mal à
tourner la caméra c'est que
même quand il a arrêté de diriger
d'être président du club de marseille il
y avait encore quand même cette ambiance
cette présence son identité dans les
tribunes et c'est ce que tous les
supporter 10 et qu'ils aient eu un an à
l'époque où il était président on peut
il en a eu 20 ou 30 ils ont toujours
senti la pâte identité la force de
bernard tapie dans les tribunes et c'est
ce qu'on ressent c'est comme ça
qu'aujourd'hui il ya énormément de
supporters se sont
pour accompagner
ce jeu
dépouille
jusque là
la jambe
m
mais
il
de nous rejoindre nous posons vivre en
direct depuis marseille les obsèques de
bernard salles de bernard tapie bernard
tapie qui va être inhumé à marseille à
la maison comme a dit son fils stéphane
au tapis un retour dans cette ville
qu'il aime et que lui a beaucoup aimé et
avec laquelle il a vécu des émotions
extraordinaires évidemment en
particulier en
1993 avec cette victoire en ligue des
champions de l'olympique de marseille
cette victoire cédric alliez vous êtes
journaliste au figaro sport elle reste
pour les marseillais mais aussi pour
pour la france une sacrée victoire est
une victoire qui ne s'est pas reproduite
et non non non pour l'instant
le paris saint germain à la sauce qatari
essaye essaye et encore mais il n'y
arrive pas ce qui démontre bien que que
ce n'est pas simple de la remporter
alors effectivement en 93 c'était une
autre époque alors les budgets des clubs
de foot était déjà très important mais
on n'était pas sur les montants
totalement astronomique d'aujourd'hui
mais oui oui marseille reste le premier
il reste à jamais dans les coeurs mais
même des amoureux du football en france
alors si on est supporters parisiens
c'est un amour particulier mais mais il
ya lee doit quand même y avoir un
certain respect c'est une certitude
sur ces images le soutien absolu un de
ses supporters à bernard tapie un
soutien qui est arrivé très vite et très
fort également lorsqu'il a annoncé sa
maladie en septembre 2010 est il était
présent également pour soutenir l'ancien
homme d'affaires oui parce que c'est
comme comme le disait très bien sache à
bernard tapie est toujours resté près du
club il c'était comme une espèce de
dhombres alors pour le pour les
différents présidents qui lui ont
succédé c'était comme une ombre
une espèce de succession très très
difficile d'apporter beaucoup se sont
cassé les dents peut-être un seul à
vraiment réussi 7 et pape diouf qui
entretenait d'ailleurs des relations
relativement proche avec bernard tapie
il n'était pas toujours sur la même
longueur loin de là mais mais en tout
cas il pape diouf avait aussi compris
cet état d'esprit marseillais et où donc
mais aujourd'hui on le voit avec avec
frank mccourt tu sais très compliqué
parce que bernard tapie était un
président très très proche de dieu comme
le propriétaire de l'olympique de
marseille aujourd'hui propriétaire
américain c'est ça exactement et qui lui
est tout l'inversé de bernard tapie
c'est à dire que bernard tapie était un
président très proche des joueurs très
présent médiatiquement dans les tribunes
du temps et frank mccourt peut-être un
peu un président fantôme aux yeux des
des marseillais et ça forcément
il souffre de ça il souffre de la
comparaison même encore aujourd'hui même
même près de près de 30 ans après il ya
toujours ce totem on voyait sur sur les
images qu'on a pu découvrir hier de cet
événement inédit est assez
extraordinaire au vélodrome hier en
hommage à bernard tapie ce cercueil sur
la pelouse du vélodrome stéphane tapis
omniprésent pour pour cet hommage avec
les supporters de marseille on a vu
stéphane tapis en lacets
l'actuel je crois que c'était le
président pablo longoria c'est ça sur la
bande le banc de le banc de touche en
assistant à cet hommage à bernard tapie
est ce que le rôle de stéphane tapis
aujourd'hui c'est de faire perdurer la
mémoire de l'ancien président de l'om
bernard tapie
est de rester présent et d'avoir
toujours un oeil dans la gestion de ce
club avec lequel bernard tapie mais un
rapport particulièrement fort il peut il
peut essayer maintenant c'était
stéphane tapie n'a jamais n'a pas l'aura
évidemment de son père donc je pense
qu'il va avoir beaucoup de mal à tenir
ce rôle je pense que
bernard tapie ne faisait lui-même même
quand il a commencé à être aidé a eu ses
problèmes de santé malheureusement qu'il
a commencé est affaibli il a été là il
commentait j'ai retrouvé des
commentaires qu'il avait fait en début
d'année quand il y avait eu
malheureusement des incidents très
important la commanderie les choses
comme ça il n'avait pas hésité à taper
sur la direction frank mccourt tu qui
avait dit que c'était une honte qu'il
fallait qu'il passe la main ce n'est pas
aux supporters de s'adapter à la culture
du président c'est au président de gérer
son club avec la pleine conscience de
l'histoire du tempérament de l'adn des
particularités du club voilà en deux
phrases on voit tout de suite ça y est
il a déjà il s'est remis les supporters
dans la poche enfin il les a jamais eu
europe et série servi dans la dans la
peau du président s'est remis dans la
peau du président et tout donc même
s'ils avaient pris des distances en
raison de son état de santé il était
quand même toujours là et surtout sa
voix comptaient énormément si s'il avait
envie de dire beaucoup de bien de frank
mccourt
ça aurait pu booster frank mccourt t
elle est d être un peu plus apprécié des
supporters marseillais alors parmi les
internautes qui vous suivent en direct
sur la chaîne youtube du figaro y sur
lefigaro.fr bien évidemment vous êtes
nombreux à nous faire part de vos
messages d'hommage à bernard tapie de
vos remerciements à l'attention du
l'homme bernard tapie à ce qu'il a
apporté à ce qu'il vous a apporté
également
ghislaine je vais citer quelques-uns
d'entre vous ghislaine de suzanne fabre
sur youtube repose en paix bernat et
condoléances sincères à toute la famille
de bernard tapie que cet honneur nous
fait bernard tapie d'avoir choisi
marseille et le cimetière de mazargues
on t'aime dit ghislaine un peu plus loin
il y a ramzy a jamais marseillais merci
boss repose en paix foulayah 13 merci
bosse également pour tout ce que tu as
fait pour l'om et marseille je t'aime on
t'aime a jamais paix à ton âme à jamais
les premiers ça c'est le slogan de
l'olympique marseillais exactement alors
ça par contre ce qui est intéressant
j'ai moi même pas là pas la réponse et
où c
est ce que c'est entre guillemets
bernard tapie qui a choisi marseille où
est ce que c'est la ville qui l'a
choisie est ce que c'est un
heureux hasard de circonstances parce
que quand il a appelé en 86 à la tête de
l'om c'est sous l'impulsion de gaston
defferre donc il ya quand même à ce
moment là c'est pas tapie ne ne vient
pas par une conviction profonde en tout
cas moi c'est le sentiment que j'ai
c'est qu'on jouait sa part d'aller à
marseille il exactement
on lui a en lui un peu pas imposé mais
en tout cas on lui a conseillé par
contre le coup de foudre va être inné
dire et on le voit ce coup de foudre bas
il est il est resté il a duré perdurer
dans le temps ce coup de foudre
réciproque on va dire et de bernard
tapie et des marseillais à son égard et
de bernard tapie à l'égard de cette
ville de marseille vous voyez sur ces
images diffusées en direct on suit le
cortège de supporters et de fans
marseillais le long de ce vieux port de
la cité phocéenne
ils suivent le cortège funéraire le
cercueil de bernard tapie qui doit
et qui prend la direction en ce moment
même de la cathédrale la major qui et
qui fait face à la méditerranée on
écoute un peu les ses supporters si vous
pouvez monter le son en régie pour nous
permettre d'avoir un retour de
l'atmosphère et de ce qui se passe sur
place
je m'avance pas
les blancs à des supporters en noir
un dresscode demandé en amont depuis
hier
via la famille et les clubs de
supporters de l'olympique de marseille
s'habille en noir portait une écharpe de
l'olympique de marseille et se rendre à
pied depuis le vieux port jusqu'à la
cathédrale de la major ou vont avoir
lieu les obsèques et cette messe en
hommage à bernard tapie à 11 heures nous
sommes en direct avec vous sur
lefigaro.fr figaro live et sur notre
chaîne youtube et vous êtes nombreux à
nous faire part de vos commentaires de
vos de votre émotion également suite à
la disparition de l'ex homme d'affaires
et de l'ancien patron de l'olympique de
marseille s'est décalé est avec nous
également en plateau il est journaliste
au service sport du figaro et puis nous
avons sacha bénite à notre envoyé
spécial qui a qui on leur donnera la
parole dans quelques minutes c'est
cédric alliés pour pour les jeunes qui
n'ont pas connu bernard tapie qui sont
pourtant aujourd'hui des fans mais qui
n'étaient même pas nés peut-être ans en
1993 ou en 1986 quand bernard tapie a
pris la présidence de l'om
comment on pourrait décrire bernard
tapie qui était-il et pourquoi ces
hommages depuis plusieurs jours à
l'égard de deux de ce personnage
alors moi moi moi j'étais j'étais jeune
également à l'époque j'étais déjà nés et
tout mais dans les années 90 est tout
pour moi je me souviens de l'image de
tapie c'était un petit peu aussi des
guignols de l'info c'était fin nanard
sévèrement burné les choses comme ça
donc bernard tapie c'était c'était un
président veut si je puis me permettre
fort en gueule c'est à dire qu'il y
avait une voix qui porte et un charisme
énorme
et puis et puis et il avait déjà de
l'avant sur tout le monde sur à la fois
la culture du buzz ils savaient
exactement comment faire parler d'eux de
marseille faire venir des stars c'était
un président
aujourd'hui jean michel aulas lui a
rendu un vibrant hommage qu'ils étaient
très forts qui inspirait beaucoup
d'autres présidents dans sa manière de
défendre son club de se mettre en avant
2 quand il ya une crise un peu sur le
terrain ok hop je vais prendre les
projecteurs sur moi et puis c'est moi
qui vais à aspirer un petit peu tout le
venin qu'on peut lire dans la presse ou
ailleurs ça il a été très très fort sa
relation avec les médias est
exceptionnel et puis il y avait une pays
d'avesnes passion une passion pour le
sport une passion pour le foot il
connaissait ça
il a pris jean pierre papin il a pris
aussi didier deschamps faut pas oublier
didier deschamps ci lui a rendu un
vibrant hommage si didier deschamps et
là c'est en france la coupe du monde 98
c'est pas grâce à bernard tapie on va
pas exagérer non plus mais didier
deschamps est devenue un immense joueur
grâce à bernard tapie alors pour
accompagner un peu ce que vous dites
cédric alliés on à balata 19 sur la
chaîne youtube du figaro et dans le chat
qui nous dit bravo bosses tu as plus
décomplexé le football français gras
soit grâce à toi le football français
est là où il est marseille restera à
jamais le plus grand club de foot
français le plus grand club de tous les
temps repose en paix boss ouais ça veut
dire beaucoup de choses mais je suis
tout à fait d'accord avec avec cet
internaute c'est à dire qu'il a c'est
aussi comment résumer bernard tapie
c'est aussi la culture de la gagne
c'était un winner absolue
bon ça n'a peut-être conduit à certaines
dérives mais c'était il savait motiver
les joueurs quand vous entendez quand il
en parle quand vous écoutez basile boli
qui a donné un entretien dans l'équipe
c'était incroyable c'est quand même un
président qui veut recruter un joueur
qui lui dit écoute pour l'instant pas
mon avis tu as pas le niveau
techniquement t'es pas bon mais si entre
guillemets tu as le courage pour ne pas
employer un mot plus plus ford de venir
à marseille tu vas devenir un grand
joueur et ça a donné les joueurs
aujourd'hui on attendait tellement
tendance à les brosser dans le sens du
poil que lui à l'époque non lui il
disait des 4 vérités il avait un franc
parler
qui dit kiki vraiment le symbolisait
donc ça c'était très fort il a vraiment
donné
pareil basile boli dizaine ya des fois
ils venaient dans le vestiaire à la
mi-temps ou avant un match et derrière
les joueurs étaient galvanisés si
lointaine sur le chat youtube du figaro
live c'était un président fait pour l'om
grands patrons à l'om d'accord dit
françois le gall ots également
je pense que beaucoup de gens on était
jaloux de bernard tapie écrit eric hui
paix à ton âme boss dit kariba 2009
un certain nombre d'entre vous sont
effectivement très impressionné par par
la carrière de bernard tapie ont
l'image d'un bernard tapie flamboyant
presque à
une personne plus comment dire une icône
une idole devrais je dire par rapport à
l'image qui pouvait renvoyer et le
modèle qui l'a inspiré pour beaucoup
beaucoup de supporters et à marseille et
ailleurs et d'un point de vue personnel
et puis d'un point de vue professionnel
également puisque vous le disais il
avait la culture de la gagne et cette
culture là il appliquer dans tous les
registres et tous les secteurs dans
lesquels il s'est aventuré exactement et
cci là il a infusé ça dans le club
peut-être peut-être tellement que quand
frank mccourt tu deviens président
duclos enfin actionnaire principal et
qu'il devient propriétaire du club il ya
ce fameux championne ce project qui
aujourd'hui
et surtout sujet de moquerie puisque
malheureusement il n'ya pas ya pas eu
beaucoup de titres mais il a cette
culture de la gagne qui infuse le club
encore aujourd'hui même s'ils n'ont pu
malheureusement les moyens financiers
pour lutter avec le paris saint germain
et ont gagné la ligue des champions n'en
parlons même pas mais il ya toujours il
ya toujours ça est ce que j'ai bien aimé
dans le commentaire d'un internaute que
vous citez sait il a été fait pour ce
club oui alors on peut toujours imaginer
j'aurais tendance à dire qu'il a été
fait pour un club du sud dans sa malgré
qu'il était né à paris il avait cette
mentalité cette flamboyance que vous a
dit kylie a des très bien avec le sud
bon est ce que ça aurait pu être ni
c'est ce que soient plus être toulouse
je ne sais pas mais mais mais quelque
part aujourd'hui ça sonne comme une
évidence tapis à marseille on n'imagine
pas ailleurs l'imaginent pas président
du paris saint-germain parce que sa
personnalité n'aurait pas coller avec le
côté un peu aseptisé de la capitale
c'était sirigu t2 sur le chat youtube de
figaro live qui ne faisait part de son
commentaire en disant c'était un
président fait pour l'om on va retrouver
sacha benita en direct depuis le cortège
des supporters de l'olympique de
marseille les supporters et des fans de
bernard tapie cortèges qui se dirigent
vers la cathédrale de la major vous que
se déroulait où va se dérouler la messe
de 11 heures en cette cathédrale qui
fait face à la méditerranée sacha benita
vous êtes aux côtés d'un femme de
bernard tapie on va vous laisser
échanger avec lui je vous laisse sacha
benita
oui
je suis plus à compter du président
10 francken ii
marseille c'est à dire qu'ils s'occupent
de permettre aux personnes handicapées
de vous
accéder au match vous étiez dans les
tribunes
guy des résidentes du bien
est ce que cette ambiance existantes
aujourd'hui
existe qui joue un petit peu mais bon
succès avec la fille ça a été quelque
chose nous a libérés voilà il nous a
libérés de beaucoup de choses qu'elle
est arrivée avait en étudier une demande
le club était pas bien mais il nous a su
voir que avec la volonté avec avec son
envie à lui avant tout parce que c'est
lui qui nous a donné la perte de pouvoir
des hommes attrapent fière d'être
marseillais il nous a dit voilà j'en
arrive j'arrive et je vais faire le
maximum pour qu'on gagne la coupe
d'europe et chapeau parce qu'il nous a
menés vraiment en extase que presque
toute la france était derrière l'om a
cette fois que la et demi
c'est pas une bonne vue
détaillée je vais venir le coup de
baguette magique
il a fait de l'om un club est reconnu
dans le monde entier je n'ai pas retenu
à l'est
et c'est ambiance elle y est toujours
mais avec les moyens allaient moins que
quand il est arrivé ce qui est arrivé on
était tous les ans
un petit peu
acheter
ma vie nous a ouverts forte d'un livre
oui
moi j'ai l'océan science âge je vous
fait envoler la ligne droite à daniel
rossellat on attend et on va y aller en
italie en sable c'est quelque chose de
merveilleux site owni moi je suis
sûrement
s'il était là je pence que je suis un
cordage
avanciez je vais dire vous nous parliez
d'ambiance là juste derrière on voit
encore les personnes qui sont en train
d'avancer vers la cathédrale qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette ambiance cet
hommage vous étiez hier aussi au
vélodrome g13 plaisir justement j'ai eu
l'honneur de porter
la photo de monsieur bernard tapie sur
le terrain
c'était vraiment je vous assure c'est
est émotionnel de voir d'ailleurs vous
avez vu pas de débordements tout le
monde a été correct is of innovation ils
ont fait tout ce qu'il fallait pour un
an 10 hommes à monsieur tapie ce qu'il
fallait c'est à dire à nous on ne parle
on parle exclusivement de l'olympique de
marseille et de monsieur triaud ne parle
pas du rasta laura sadis en dessous nous
sommes ce tapis quand il est arrivé il a
voulu fuir à des choses il est en tête
et il a très bien fait à table merci
beaucoup monsieur de rien tout à fait
logique
si je reprenne mon service tintin com
parle de demandes associations ces
problèmes
merci à chercher un jour je sais pas
merci sacha benita pour pau cette
interview de 2,2 ce supporter
marseillais président d'une association
qui favorise l'entraidé des supporters
handicapés dans les stades
vous êtes un bon bras nous suivre sur
les réseaux sociaux du figaro à nous
faire part de vos commentaires de vos
questions
il est aussi nombreux depuis l'étranger
puisque je vois que yaakov me money qui
habite en israël bonjour yaakov vous
nous dites j'habite en israël bernard
tapie grâce à toi tu as réalisé mon rêve
de gosse de gagner la ligue des
champions la ligue de champions pour
l'om allez l'om repose en paix on ne
t'oubliera jamais on est certain aussi
comparé bernard tapie ou 10 de bernard
tapie qu il leur ferait rougir les
américains au vu de d'effectivement des
hommages qui lui sont rendus et de
l'impact il a pu avoir en tant que comme
d'affaires sur la vie de nombreux
français qu'est ce qu'on peut dire de sa
cédric alliés
c'est ce qui l'a très bien dit ce
ce supporters c'est que
en 93
il faut il faut pas se tromper toute la
france était derrière était derrière
l'om même même même un certain nombre de
supporters parisiens s'étaient ils
avaient ils avaient fédérer tout le
monde tout le monde derrière lui après
ce qu'il y à diviser c'est évidemment la
sphère au mba et toute la suite mais en
93 au moment de la finale de ligue des
champions contre milan tout le monde est
bleu et blanc c'est clair et net et
apparemment aussi également en europe en
plus milan était un club qu'on aimait
que beaucoup en europe aimer détester
donc quelque part certains sont mis à
adorer marseille aussi pour ça je parle
en europe 1 pas maintenant la ville donc
c'était il a fédéré autour de sa
personnalité autour du club et son aura
a dépassé nos frontières en tout cas
peut-être pour une communauté française
se trouvant à l'étranger preuve en est
elle le supporters que je viens de citer
qui vit en israël et qui supportaient
donc l'olympique de marseille les images
que vous découvrez en ce moment nous
proviennent donc de marseille mais cette
fois-ci non pas du cortège mais de la
foule qui attend devant la cathédrale la
major où doit avoir lieu la messe
des obsèques de bernard tapie à partir
de 11h et vous le voyez ce cortège qui
continue d'avancer depuis le vieux port
jusqu'à cette cathédrale
cortège nombreux avec un certain nombre
de supporters essentiellement mais aussi
des marseillais le mot d'ordre était de
dress code obligatoire en tout cas
encourager pour cette matinée
particulière était le noir avec le bleu
et le blanc couleur symbolique de
l'olympique de marseille
vous voyez des familles des femmes ou
des hommes des enfants
se rassemblent donc et marche sur cette
route qui longe à la fois le vieux port
et le bord de mer
le lien très fort entre bernard tapie et
cette ville un lien tout à fait
réciproque un amour tout à fait
réciproque en préparant cette émission
j'ai pu lire un certain nombre de
commentaires de personnes qui côtoyaient
bernard tapie et qui analysait ce lien
très particulier avec cette ville
quelqu'un disait en faisant du bien à
l'om il a fait du bien à la ville et un
autre disait c'est un marseillais qui
s'ignoraient encore une fois
c'est assez particulier parce qu'on se
dit qu'il n'ya pas d'autres bernard
tapie aujourd'hui en france et qu'il n'y
en a pas eu d'autre il était une
exception dans un paysage
assez particulier et on le voit
aujourd'hui à travers ces célébrations
bernard tapie étonnamment il a eu il a
eu dix mille vit une vie de politique
une vie d'acteur une vie de comédien une
vie de deux business man et tout est
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que on ne
parle que de l'om on ne parle que du
bernard tapie président président de
club donc ça ça quasiment éclipsé tout
le reste
la commune est ministre et pourtant
aujourd'hui on n'en parle pas pas tant
que ça c'est cesser ses pressions non
c'est pas presque c'est irrationnel en
fait c'est cette histoire là alors qu'on
voit des images de certaines
personnalités qui se sont donc
approché de la cathédrale avant d'y
entrer en vue de cette messe qui doit se
dérouler à partir de 11h on voit basile
boli jeu l'animateur jean luc reichmann
est également présent je crois que c'est
stéphane tapis que l'on voit de dos qui
s'avance vers basile boli
eric di meco des joueurs emblématiques à
l'époque à l'époque de l'eau web alors
je ne sais pas et on ne sait pas si les
personnalités qui étaient présentes à
saint-germain-des-prés seront présentes
également aujourd'hui pour les obsèques
de bernard tapie un certain nombre
d'entre elles probablement en tout cas
les anciens joueurs de l'om comme basile
boli ou ou jean pierre papin qui étaient
donc présents à saint germain des prés
on en parlait tout à l'heure du lien de
bernard tapie non pas simplement avec
les supporters mais aussi avec ses
joueurs et effectivement l'attachement
des marseillais on le retrouve dans dans
des joueurs de l'om on le retrouve dans
les mots quoi puis prononcer jean pierre
papin ou basile boli il avait cet
attachement qui allait au-delà de la
simple présidence d'un club il était
avec eux ils partageaient un quotidien
même des années après il était resté
très proche d'un jean pierre papin
basile boli oui oui c'était vraiment un
président qui était très proche de ses
joueurs c'est c'était presque enfin pas
je pense que c'était sans doute un
président entraîneur d'une certaine
façon donc
il ya certains joueurs qui lui doivent
tout leur carrière jean pierre papin et
didier deschamps partie enfin ils le
doivent aussi à leur talent évidemment
mais mais bernard tapie a su leur à
infuser la culture de la gagne et c'est
vrai qu'il y a il a gardé ce lien il
avait il avait je pense aussi c'est ça
qui explique aujourd'hui l'amour de des
marseillais sait qu'il avait cette
fidélité ce n'était pas quelqu'un qui
ait oublié ce n'était pas quelqu'un qui
se refermait sa porte une fois quand il
quand il a quitté l'om il n'a pas homme
je m'en vais et puis d'ailleurs il est
revenue malheureusement au début des
années 2000 bon ça pas été sa plus
grande réussite mais mais même ça ça n'a
pas entaché son image en ce ce come-back
un peu un peu raté mais il a il a
toujours toujours garder ce lien cet
amour c'est un passionné c'est un
passionné de sport donc forcément je
pense qu'ils avaient une part
d'admiration pour ce que pouvait réussir
ses joueurs et cette admiration lui
donner envie ensuite de garder le
contact et d'en rester proche et de les
soutenir peut-être de les conseiller
c'était très fort
et toujours ce cortège de supporters et
de marseillais qui est
se dirige lentement mais sûrement de
voix je dire vers la cathédrale de la
major on va se dérouler la messe des
obsèques de bernard tapie à partir de 11
heures on a pu voir quelques
personnalités déjà à l'entrée de cette
cathédrale
m
et
3h10 moi je pense que la rue sabiine
y en a marre
m
vous voyez sur ces images depuis
marseille donc le cortège qui continue
sa progression en direction de la
cathédrale de la major on va se dérouler
la messe des obsèques de bernard tapie à
partir de 11h jeu si quelques-uns de vos
commentaires sur les réseaux sociaux du
figaro sur lefigaro.fr max nous raconte
j'avais 10 ans en 1990 j'allais au stade
avec mon père c'était tellement magique
que de belles émotions merci bernard
tapie
l'émotion est forte aussi chez
max de nouveau pardon max à kindi avec
monsieur tapie tout était possible il
transformer les rêves en réalité
c'est vrai est effectivement qu'il avait
sept et il garde encore cette image et
de quelqu'un qui tout réussissait et
qu'ils étaient capables de transformer
les choses en positif si on reste sur
l'image positive de bernard tapie je
sais que beaucoup d'entre vous nous
reproche le fait de s'enthousiasmer sur
le personnage aujourd'hui mais on est
sur la ville de marseille et le soutien
des marseillais à bernard tapie
aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur les
affaires effectivement on parle du sport
on parle de ce qu'il a fait avec
l'olympique de marseille en 93 et à
partir du moment où il a repris la
présidence de cette équipe en est de ce
club en 1986
ces deux cas liés qui est avec nous qui
est journaliste du sport j'aimerais
savoir comment comment justement il mène
l'olympique de marseille la victoire
c'est quoi sa stratégie c'est quoi la
méthode tapie alors elle et elle est
complexe à l'est
déjà il ya sa propre personne son propre
caractère donc sa capacité à motiver ses
troupes sa capacité à aller chercher des
jeunes joueurs qui est qui va faire
grandir sa capacité à aller chercher des
stars sa capacité à aller chercher des
entraîneurs comme raymond goethals qu'on
appelait raymond la science qui a été un
peu le l'entraîneur symbolique de de
l'ère tapie même s'il n'a pas été le
seul c'est celui qui a eu lieu la plus
grande réussite et puis je pense qu'ils
savaient ils savaient mixer tout ça il a
su fédérer une un club et surtout une
ville derrière cette équipe il a créé
une passion et tout c'est vrai que quand
on dit transformer les rêves en réalité
c'est un président qui arrive qui en 86
qui prend une équipe qui est seulement
12e de ligue 1 qui dit on va aller
gagner la ligue des champions ils
peuvent aller gagner le championnat de
france ils parlent carrément d'europe
coc aujourd'hui on va dire il a un melon
comme ça c'est très prétentieux on va
voir sept ans après il y arrive c'est
sept ans et on voit le paris saint
germain et tout malgré tous les moyens
qui ont été mis n'arrive toujours pas la
gagner cette ligue des champions donc
c'est pas là il ya une méthode tapis
mais il ya une part de une petite part
de magie de de quelque chose qu'on peut
pas donc on peut pas décrire il a il a
réussi vraiment à à tout tout tout
ordonné dans le bon moment c'est il
s'est très peu trompé dans son
recrutement c'est assez fabuleuse qu'il
a réussi à faire c'est pour ça que la
ville de marseille lui rend un hommage
aujourd'hui jeu j'entends bien tout tout
tout les affaires mais c'est
effectivement c'est pas le c'est pas le
sujet aujourd'hui je pense qu'à un
moment donné quelqu'un qui vient de
disparaître il ya une part négatif chez
bernard tapie personne ne niera mais
aujourd'hui on est là vraiment pour
célébrer cette réussite là cet amour et
je pense qu'il faut il faut savoir un
moment donné dans un moment de
recueillement mettre un peu de côté
cette part des ténèbres que pouvait
peut-être avoir bernard tapie et voilà
lui rendre l'hommage qu'ils méritent
dans la dans sa ville de coeur
on le voit sur ces images des banderoles
tapis à jamais notre boss ont suspendu
des marseillais à leur fenêtre
sur ce trajet du convoi funéraire que
suivent les supporters marseillais les
marseillais depuis depuis ce matin en
direction de la cathédrale où doit avoir
lieu la messe à partir de 11 heures vous
suivez en direct avec nous les obsèques
de bernard tapie bernard tapie disparu
dimanche dernier et qui depuis fait
beaucoup parler effectivement et dans
l'aspect positif que représentait le
personnage est aussi dans l'aspect
beaucoup plus sombre comme vous le
disiez cédric qu'allié mais ça ce n'est
pas le propos effectivement
d'aujourd'hui puisqu'on est sur
l'hommage les obsèques de la ville de
marseille des marseillais à l'égard de
bernard tapie et on l'a souligné
effectivement depuis le début de ce
direct que les marseillais dans leur
ensemble ne tiennent pas rigueur et les
supporters en tout cas à bernard tapie
des affaires qui ont pu accompagner sa
carrière on voit arriver en direct le
corbillard dans lesquelles se trouve le
cercueil
de l'ancien président de l'om
monseigneur jean marc aveline qui va
célébrer cette messe dans quelques
minutes on a pu voir
à pied depuis le plus haut
cathédrale qui fait face à la
méditerranée en haut des marches on
aperçoit stéphane tapis
de nouveau cette banderole et maintenant
les fumigènes
brandie par les fenêtres de cet immeuble
sur le parcours du cortège funéraire
dont le corbillard autre juste d'arriver
devant la cathédrale de la major japon
les barrières
et toujours donc ce cortège de
supporters de fans de marseillais réunis
depuis ce matin 9h sur le vieux port de
marseille se sont donnés rendez-vous
avec pour consigne d'être vêtus de noir
et de ne porter que du bleu et du blanc
et d'accompagner donc le cortège
funéraire et le corbillard de bernard
tapie jusqu'à cette cathédrale de la
major on va se dérouler cette messe
à 11 heures
des bouquets de fleurs vont être
installés dans l'église on entendait en
arrière fond la voix
une femme qui chante apparemment des
chansons entonnées dents
puis l'intérieur de cette cathédrale
elle y est certains s'interrogeaient sur
la possibilité que marseille choisissez
un lieu pour le baptiser du nom de
bernard tapie beaucoup évidemment
d'évoquer le stade vélodrome est ce que
le stade vélodrome pourrait être
rebaptisé le beernaert bernard tapie
avec le nom de bernard tapie alors
d'après d'après ce que j'ai entendu et
d'après les échos que j'ai eus de
marseille ça va être très compliqué en
tout cas à court terme puisqu'il ya le
fameux naming que maintenant ça
s'appelle l' orange vélodrome que don
qui ont donné à 10 heures orange la
marque orange de téléphonie exactement
donc ça vient il ya un aspect financier
qui est très fort donc pour l'instant
c'est une hypothèse plutôt écarté
maintenant ils peuvent très bien faire
une place une statue de vent ou de ou
des choses comme ça il y aura moyen lui
rendre hommage et puis et puis là on est
sur un moment de recueillement très fort
mais il faut pas oublier qu'un aura sans
doute un autre qui est qui qui sera très
attendu par le peuple marseillais dans
neuf jours notre marseille va recevoir
lorient en championnat ça sera le
premier match au vélodrome depuis le la
disparition de bernard tapie je pense
que la direction de l'om a intérêt à
réussir ce
un grand effort hommage à ce moment là
parce que là il y aura vraiment un stade
un stade rempli et c'est ça va être
aussi un fort moment d'émotion même si
là c'est sûr que
devant cette magnifique cathédrale de la
major c'est c'est un moment fort pour la
famille
fort pour la famille on parlait de
sophie tapie de stéphane tapis ses
enfants on n'a pas parlé de sa femme qui
est un pays fort du clan tapis
qui l'a soutenu dans les mauvais moments
et dans les bons moments évidemment
j'aimerais qu'on parle cédric alliés
juste quelques quelques minutes quelques
secondes de de son frère le frère de
bernard tapie qu'on a vu lors de la
messe funéraire mercredi à saint germain
des prés qui doit probablement être là
aujourd'hui a aussi réalisé à le même
exploit que son frère c'était le le
président du club de handball de l'om
vitrolles au début des années 90 et dans
les semaines qui ont suivi la victoire
de l'om lui même est bien à gagner une
coupe d'europe c'est assez
extraordinaire cette histoire là c'était
c'était assez assez incroyable c'était
une époque où le handball français
comment c'est simplement un petit peu a
pointé le bout de son nez il avait il
avait fédéré un peu une dream team
française autour de jackson richardson
et deux joueurs emblématiques
à l'époque c'est vrai alors
malheureusement
le club a très vite disparu ensuite donc
ça c'est
aujourd'hui je ne saurais pas vous dire
exactement à quel niveau joue l'om
vitrolles mais c'est qu'ils sont
vraiment redescendu très bas mais c'est
vrai qu'il y avait eu une réussite c'est
peut-être aussi ça l'amour aussi de
c'est un amour aujourd'hui qu'on exprime
à un homme mais c'est aussi peut-être à
une famille également donc que c'est
c'est cette réussite du handball était
c'était c'était un petit détail mais qui
qui donne une dimension
particulière à la réussite sportive que
les tapis ont connu dans la cité
phocéenne alors vous voyez à l'instant
le cercueil prix va être
portée
jusqu'à l'intérieur de cette cathédrale
de la major en présence vous voyez de la
famille de bernard tapie
cercueil précédé par monseigneur jean
marc levin qui va célébrer cette messe
merci de nous transmettre cet hommage à
bernard tapie cet homme génial un merci
marseille nous témoigne nicole fait
nicole pec pardon sur le tchat
du figaro
viard alive youtube
le nombre de personnes présentes dans le
cortège démontre à lui seul l'amour et
l'attachement du peuple marseillais
envers ce grand monsieur merci nous dit
un autre internaute sur le chat de notre
chaîne youtube alors qu'on voit avancer
encore le cortège
des supporters de bernard tapie de
l'olympique de marseille
qui s'avance vers cette cathédrale où va
débuter la messe des obsèques de bernard
tapie
on
des prix pour les corps tout
celui-ci au bar et de bas
comme chaque jour ou presque avec eux
moi
ouais
sur ces images et on entendait les
supporters d'un de en tout cas
je crois si j'ai bien entendu précisé
qu' un certain nombre d'entre eux à la
demande de la famille avec
l'autorisation de la famille de bernard
tapie pourra entrer dans cette
cathédrale de la major pour assister à
la messe des obsèques de l'ancien
président de l'om certains d'entre eux
j'imagine et les présidents des clubs de
supporters direct alliés qui vont
pouvoir avoir cette chance va dire un
local en ce moment assez émouvant pour
eux d'entrer dans cette église et puis
d'assister à cette à cette messe ils
vont pouvoir lui rendre hommage comme
ils ont pu lui rendre hommage aussi hier
au vélodrome qui a percuté un homme un
instant magnifique moi ce que j'ai envie
de voir aussi c'est vraiment on voit
dans les dents les images qu'on a là il
n'y a pas de débordements marseille est
souvent présenté comme la ville de tous
les excès aujourd'hui on voit surtout un
excès d'amour pour un homme qui a
symbolisé la réussite du club et de la
ville donc ça je trouve que c'est
magnifique je pense qu'il ya vraiment
cette volonté des supporters de de ne
pas rater cet hommage et on voit
aujourd'hui on voit l'aspect le plus
positif de la ville de marseille et ça
c'est aussi ce qu'il faudra retenir de
cette journée
l'aspect le plus positif de la ville de
marseille sans débordement effectivement
depuis ce matin les supporters les
marseillais sont pu se réunir sur le
vieux port de marseille pour accompagner
le cercueil de bernard tapie et lors
d'un convoi funéraire entre le vieux
port et en direction de la cathédrale de
la major on va débuter dans quelques
secondes maintenant la messe en hommage
à bernard tapie ce sont ses obsèques
aujourd'hui que nous avons fait vivre en
direct on va retrouver maintenant une
dernière fois notre envoyé spécial qui
était au coeur de ce cortège de
supporters une dernière fois sa chance
avait dit à peut-être le témoignage d'un
de ses supporters venus aujourd'hui
témoigner son amour pour bernard tapie
et son soutien à sa famille
je suis plus avec un supporter du sport
tas mais plutôt avec une habitante de
morsay une marseillaise s'appelle
gabriel et qui est venu lui rendre
hommage
gabriel en quoi c'est important pour
vous d'être là aujourd'hui à cet hommage
l'idée c'est clichy
j'aimais beaucoup
il a dit vous inculquer des valeurs cet
homme
laval qc valeurs qui sort tout bon son
courage sa force sa volonté ça oblige
compte que ces débats l'heure qu'il est
règne
j'attends
c'est bien fait
offerte
je pense que ce qu'il a écrit au jeune
c'était
c'est bien aussi des valeurs positives
et d'ailleurs tout le monde
c'était le ba ba de marseille vous le
considérez aussi comme le boss quand on
peut entendre le père de marseille
goss le père non pas le perdre
vous allez bien avec l'image de la ville
grant google
un personnage
voilà
l'effort est
je n'ai pas à l'ouvrir
marçais
merci beaucoup vers lille
d'abord
on dirait marseille
l'hommage de la ville et l'hommage des
supporters de marseille à bernard tapie
dont tu ce sont les obsèques aujourd'hui
personnage effectivement hors du commun
on l'a souvent répété adulé ou détesté
on a pu le voir sur sur le chat du
figaro en particulier on pourra dire
qu'il est il a marqué son époque malgré
tout et que nombreux sont les
internautes et les fans de bernard tapie
avoir souligné son courage exceptionnel
face à la maladie merci beaucoup cédric
alliés d'avoir été avec nous on dirait
que ce matin pour commenter cet
événement d'un point de vue sportif et
de commenter c'est d'avoir commenté
cette union 7 cet amour entre bernard
tapie et la ville de marseille et les
supporters de marseille et
réciproquement l'amour que portait
bernard tapie à cette ville qui lui a
beaucoup beaucoup donné on l'a vu et
beaucoup apporté merci encore de nous
avoir suivis en direct sur figaro live
merci de nous avoir suivi également sur
le chat youtube du figaro mais on se
retrouve très vite sur lefigaro.fr et
sur youtube à très bientôt